وبذلك يكون العدد 18 رافعه يتم تم ارسالها
الى المنطقه كما ايضا الطائرات مثل ما
قلنا في المؤتمرات السابقه تقوم باسعاف
المنكوبين
ونقل الجرحى
بالنسبه
للاقامه
طبعا
هناك
طبعا بعض
[موسيقى]
اشخاص الذين تلقوا الدعم والمساعدات
حول
الخيم
والمعدات المطبخ
والبطانيات
[موسيقى]
نحن نقوم بتوجيه
المساعدات لهؤلاء الناس طبعا بالنسبه
لمراكز الاقامه ليس فقط الخيام بل ايضا
قلنا في المؤتمرات السابقه ان ايضا السكن
الطلاب والفنادق
والمضافات
جميعها مفتوحه
المنكوبين الان
وخمسين شخص يستفيدون من المضافات التابعه
لوزاره التعليم
وايضا
في الجامعات
والمضافات التابعه
عفوا اريد ان اجدد رقم وزاره التعليم
هناك تحديث
دائما يطرا على هذه الارقام
[موسيقى]
من
الاشخاص المعكوبين
الان
يقتلون مراكز الرياضه والملاعب
كثير طلبته
من طرف اخر بالنسبه للغذاء الهلال الاحمر
يلعب دورا
مهمه في هذه العمليه ايضا
ادارات المحليه
في المدن يقومون بالتنسيق عمليه توزيع
الغذاء
الطعام الساخن
على المنكوبين حتى الان الهلال الاحمر
وايضا وزاره التعليم
تقوم بتوزيع الغذاء
مرش في
مرعشين والبستان وانطاكيا وكركان
وبيسني
يتم توزيع
الطعام على المنكوبين
[موسيقى]
الهلال الاحمر
بالفعاليات التوزيع
الطعام الساخن والشوربه على المنكوبين
وسيواصل دعمه لهذه الفئه من الناس طبعا
اريد ان ازودكم ببعض التفاصيل
على عمليه التدفئه وعلى على عمليه التواصل
والاتصال
بعد المؤتمر الذي عقدناه
سته موزعات للكهرباء
الان خارجه عن
العمل
وباقي
الموزعات نقاط التوزيع
التواصل
فعالياتها
وهناك ايضا
الموزعات المتنقله التي يتم الان نقلها
الى هذه المنطقه في بحلول الاربعاء
والخميس والجمعه
سيتم الوصول الى هذه المنطقه
تم ايصال
الكهرباء الى قهر
الريحانيه الان فقط منتصف او نصف
الريحانيه تصل يصلها الكهرباء
[موسيقى]
ايضا
ننتظر تاييد اداره الكهرباء بان ايصال
الخط الكهربائي ليس خطرا
لكي نفتح تيار الكهربائي
هذه المحافظه اسبانيا
في مدينه العثمانيه
ايضا سيتم
الفحص
الشبكه اذا كانت لن تؤثر على عمليه
الانقاذ
وسيتم فتح التيارات كهربائي